cargo ships are the lifeblood of
international trade but it's a polluting
business and this hard to regulate
industry has been under pressure to
clean up
now the United Nations International
Maritime organization known as the IMO
has promised for the first time to get
shipping to Net Zero carbon emissions by
or around 2050.
as you know the maritime
decarbonization strategy
has been one of the most important
profit for last over 10 years
shipping emissions are currently a big
problem global Shipping carries about 90
percent of the world's traded goods and
produces nearly three percent of all
carbon emissions about the same as
omitted by Germany every year for some
then any progress is good news what was
agreed here at the IMO in London is
the first time ever that we have a
greenhouse gas emission strategy a
decarbonization of shipping the
international shipping industry it's a
very important sector we can't say we're
ever going to abandon shipping anytime
soon it's we know that's for thousands
of years but we need to decarbonate but
as temperatures continue to rise this
week setting Global records for the
hottest days ever recorded campaigners
say the Imo's pledge is too vague weak
and lacks a delivery plan we expected
them to
um to come up with goals targets for the
global Shipping sector in line with what
it takes for their fair share for the
world to limit warming to 1.5 degrees
and unfortunately they missed a boat on
that the fuels and technology that would
drive any transition are still a long
way off for this critical industry its
journey to Net Zero likely to be an
imperfect one
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News